à l'entraînement des aigles bleues
emilie bouchard enfile son masque un
masque comme en portent toutes les
gardiennes de but what i mais celui ci
est orné d'un ange et du logo d isf des
c'est-à-dire de watford et rennes qui
veut dire fait le tour des rues c'est un
hommage à une ancienne coéquipière à
ottawa qui s'est suicidé en novembre
2010 dernier cette jeune fille à votre
gauche avec le manteau blanc avait tout
pour réussir
mais personne ne se doutait que des
jeunes âgés de 14 ans avait des
problèmes de santé mentale
sa mort a été fortement médiatisée car
son père lokeren était l'entraîneur
adjoint des sénateurs d'ottawa dans la
ligue nationale de hockey le suicide a
ébranlé ses amis et ses coéquipières
c'est un deuil médiatisé donc à chaque
jour 700 dans le visage que sont
facebook les nouvelles ne peut pas vivre
un moment seuls à toi main
du
un certain point de ma vie ça te fait
réfléchir ça fait réfléchir sur le sens
de ces personnages là qu'est ce que six
personnes deux frères justin fille qui
avec des beaunois qui est bonne à
l'école tout ça donc sur luge j'avais
plus de ressemblances mais est ce que
moi ça va
emilie bouchard s'est engagé avec la
fondation des isd mis sur pied par les
parents de deron ils veulent inspirer
les jeunes à s'ouvrir aux autres à les
sensibiliser à l'importance de parler
avec leurs parents selon l'association
canadienne pour la santé mentale
le taux de suicide chez les jeunes
canadiens est le troisième plus élevée
des pays industralisés 12% des jeunes
filles et 5% des jeunes garçons ont
connu un épisode de dépression
pour emile et la communication est
essentielle elle veut effacer les
préjugés sur la santé mentale
le suicide de sa coéquipière lui a fait
comprendre bien des choses à l'école
mais avec 7 10 kilos que j'ai su
surmonter avec ma famille j'ai plaisir à
oscar de surmonter ça je peux sans
monter amenez moi des défis cinq ans
plus tard la gardienne de but des aigles
bleus poursuit ses efforts de
sensibilisation surtout que le sujet est
tabou dans le monde du sport on n'est
pas des super héros on a nos propres
problèmes aussi quand on vit avec ça on
va s'entraîner le mental on va
s'entraîner physique qui ensemble ont
fait en sorte est ici françois leblanc
et du canada à monter